I'm now gonna pretend this is me as an
actor I'm now gonna pretend I'm not in
pain all right well let's see how that
goes this next one is the bomb how'd you
get a chicken with a nuke slap my friend
that big hug
wait till you bite into it tastes like
your grandfather's big toe go bomb be on
instead of the hot sauce this is the
bomb
beyond insanity it says seems like a
good idea
[Music]
just dive in hmm now we're getting into
real territory here mm hmm hmm
this was articulate right out of the
gate Kansas don't know how to do no hot
wings
yeah feel it do you feel heat I think I
singed my eyebrows with that [ __ ] I'm
now [ __ ] crawling over [ __ ] wing
my eyes are tearing short period of
happiness oh my god that's so hard I
think I'm losing my mind how long have
we been here
it's we've been here for three days I
feel drunk
Caliente sauce like a damn breech birth
like I'm [ __ ] coming out backwards
hold on
we got damn heart rates about 130 uh
what do you take for this almond milk ah
well now is there anything else to eat
we have some bread this is cheating are
people gonna call me out for truth oh
you know just drinking wax out of this
sex candle and then eating the bomb
chicken wing Shawn you're making it
sound weird when you say it like that
the lime does that work take a lap
scarlet I've had plenty of laps plenty
of laps godly boy I can't even speak my
mouth is actually numb how long is the
tour later you know it's a it's an
adventure for everyone careful on the
eyes careful around your eyes
careful around your eyes careful around
your eyes careful around your eyes oh
why don't you touch your eyes they did I
caught some sauce in the eyes Oh No
let's take five minute break yeah oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man
we've reached the ceiling I think we're
at maximum levels who to borrow a phrase
from my friend Joe Jeanne sauvé
a fire I feel in my ears oh it's like
it's like coming from within yeah
yesterday's I'm reminded you these are
the crevices are you going back in her
yeah it's just hot and bitter but I'm
gonna do it I will not be done just
feeding
oh it's just pain what why there's no
good memories I just remembered some per
long time ago oh just what got me oh
dear yeah yeah yeah hey Tim yeah me
Dylan can I take my shirt off this is
what you having a good time
this is a scare cop I can't do this this
is really crazy it's crazy it's crazy
do you ever think do you ever think
about the absurdity of it all if I we've
got to do it we got you oh we're in it
together pull my hand I got you we're in
this together
uh-huh [ __ ] you shoddy [ __ ] how
horrible
you